It’s very important that we have this department
now, at this current time,
Crowds Chant "I Can't Breathe"
because our nation needs the kinds of knowledge
that this department produces and will continue
to produce.
Columbia has a longstanding traditions in
what we would call now African-American Studies
or Black Studies, you know, going back to
the days of Franz Boas but even in particular
after 1968
We see ourselves as a Harlem institution.
I mean African-American studies at Columbia
joins the Schomburg and Harlem Stage and the
Studio Museum and all of those like august
Harlem institutions of intellectuals from
the United States, the Caribbean, and Africa,
all of whom are committed to the very best
scholarly work
We now join them as a full-fledged department
at the University.